das klinge jetzt für die fdp der
tourismuspolitische sprecher als erster
das wort sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
deutschland braucht einen tapetenwechsel
und das so schnell wie möglich nach über
einem jahr panini mit massiven
einschränkungen besuchs verboten und
kräfteraubenden homeschooling sehen sich
millionen von menschen nach einem
überfälligen urlaub und einer
überfälligen auszeit und genau die
wollen wir als freie demokraten nun
ermöglichen denn sicheres reisen ist
möglich da ist diskutierte oster urlaub
auf mallorca hat doch gezeigt dass
verantwortungsvolles reisen unter
einbeziehung aller notwendigen
schutzmaßnahmen absolut möglich ist und
dass die zahlen eben nicht ansteigen was
mallorca schafft und was uns
österreicher diese woche vor macht das
kann deutschland so lange
daher fordern wir die bundesregierung
die große koalition noch einmal auf das
verbot von touristischen übernachtungen
ganz deutschland abzuschaffen wir haben
das als fdp bereits vor wochen hier
beantragt passiert ist nichts werden sie
endlich tätig damit familien zu
pfingsten und dem sommer endlich auch
wieder verreisen können brauchen wir den
inlands und den auslandstourismus
gleichermaßen
vor allem aber brauchen wir wieder ein
stück normalität und dazu können die
besten gastgeber der welt unsere
mittelständischen betriebe und ihre
engagierten mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter einen ganz ganz wichtigen
beitrag leisten zu den erfolgreichen
neustart der branche meine damen und
herren ist ein einheitlicher
bundesweiter öffnungs plan unerlässlich
doch diesen bleibt uns schwarz-rot
weiterhin schuldig wer im november über
nacht ganze wirtschaftszweige schließt
der muss doch nach sieben monaten auch
einen plan haben wir diese wieder
eröffnet
wie das gelingen kann meine damen und
herren haben wir als bundestagsfraktion
mehrfach jetzt hier schon im deutschen
bundestag vorgestellt so auch in unserem
vorliegenden antrag
lassen sie mich zwei punkte
herausgreifen erstens wollen wir
freidemokraten ganz deutschland zu einem
vorzeigeland für sicheres reisen machen
die seit wochen laufende modellprojekte
ich denke jan schleswig holstein
zeigen doch eindrucksvoll wie es
erfolgreich gelingen kann
und genau dieses prinzip wollen wir
jetzt für die gesamte republik
übertragen
einheitlichkeit meine damen und herren
ist der schlüssel zum erfolg damit wir
nicht wieder einen förderer ein
flickenteppich bekommen der eine
vernünftige reiseplanung unmöglich macht
die ferien stehen vor der tür es reicht
also nicht sich mit diesem
entscheidenden thema erst am 10 juni wie
sie das blatt liebe koalition zu
beschäftigen es muss jetzt gehandelt
werden
wir müssen zweitens bei den wirtschafts
hilfen am ball bleiben denn die pandemie
wird uns doch weit über den 30 juni wenn
die überbrückungshilfe drei ausläuft ja
beschäftigen auch dazu finden sie eine
ganze reihe von ideen in unserem antrag
besonders wichtig ist mir dass wir nach
liefern müssen ich denke zum beispiel an
private fällen haus betreiber die
bislang leer ausgegangen sind und an
verbundene unternehmen zum beispiel
mittelständische hotelketten für diese
kämpfen seit also diese kämpfen seit
monaten mit einer massiven unterdeckung
im hohen millionenbetrag für sie
brauchen wir also unverzüglich eine
angemessene lösung das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat laut
presseberichten er jetzt einen vorschlag
vorgelegt der auf dem tisch von
bundesfinanzminister scholz lead sehr
geehrter herr scholz beweisen sie
endlich mal dass auch ein stück
sozialdemokrat in ihnen steckt und dass
ihnen die existenzen von 10.000
hotelangestellten und deren familien
eben nicht vollends egal sind sorgen sie
für mehr fairness bei den crooner helfen
denn es kann nicht sein dass
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer in
diesem land die mehr als 249
arbeitsplätze schaffen dermaßen durch
die latten von euch den rost fallen
sorgen sie für mehr fairness jetzt haben
sie die chance dazu meine damen und
herren über 240.000 mittelständische
tourismusbetriebe und drei millionen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter sind
bereit für die neustadt
diese menschen haben in der pandemie zum
schutz von uns allen zum schutz der
allgemeinheit massive wirtschaftliche
und persönliche opfer gebracht
dafür verdienen sie unseren aufrichtigen
dank und jetzt die chance in ganz
deutschland wieder mit der arbeit
loslegen zu können
[Applaus]
barßel klinger hat hier noch mal den
antrag der fdp vorgestellt und der
nächste redner wird erwin an paul
lehrieder sprecher für tourismus von der
csu
[Applaus]
präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen das mit einem lob an die fdp
anfangs der kollege klinge herzlichen
dank dass sie mit der aufsetzung dieses
tagesordnungspunktes diese wichtigkeit
des tourismus in der kanzler- debatte
ermöglicht haben
das ist es auch dafür kann man dann
gesagt nicht gesagt aber damit hört auch
schon wieder auf zehn damen und herren
ich freue mich sehr über die gelegenheit
heute über die situation des deutschen
tourismuswirtschaft sprechen zu können
nach vielen monaten der durch strecke
betriebsschließungen
betriebseinschränkungen
reisebeschränkungen geht es jetzt
endlich wieder aufwärts mit der branche
eine branche mit immerhin etwa drei
millionen beschäftigten wirst sehen
starke zuwächse bei der buchung von
auslandsreisen jetzt wo wir dafür die
qualität auflagen faktisch abgeschafft
haben und durch eine testpflicht ersetzt
haben das heißt bei reiserückkehrern ist
die quarantäne eben entspannt hier
entfallen und da natürlich eine test
blick eben ermöglicht dass die menschen
auch wieder reisen können auch in
deutschland lassen die rückläufige
infektionszahlen immer mehr öffnung zu
ist nicht ganz so wie sie ausgeführt hat
mein kollege klinge sondern tatsächlich
eben mehr und mehr länder öffnen immer
mehr bundesländer erlauben nicht nur die
außen und teilweise auch die in
gastronomie sondern auch touristische
reisen und hotelübernachtungen und das
nicht nur an der deutschen nord und
ostseeküste
auch im beliebtesten deutschen
urlaubsland in bayern können ab morgen
hotels pensionen ferienwohnungen
campingplätzen und jugendherbergen in
regionen mit einer stabilen incidents
unter 100 wieder für touristen öffnen
das gilt auch für freizeiteinrichtungen
seilbahnen die flossen 10 schiff hat für
den kulturbereich für
sportveranstaltungen damit ist in vielen
bayerischen regionen jetzt tatsächlich
an pfingsturlaub möglich schneller als
das vor wenigen wochen noch für
möglichkeiten
es erklingen ist haben völlig zu recht
das modellprojekt schleswig-holstein
angesprochen in vielen regionen
funktioniert und jawohl wir haben schutz
der bevölkerung schutz von leib und
leben unsere mitbürger der mitbürger
einerseits aber natürlich auch den
erhalt dieser branche andererseits in
einer ausgewogenen austrainierten
verhältnisse in den letzten monaten auf
die reihe bekommen und für die im
nächsten monat beginnenden sommerferien
können deutsche urlaubsgebiete auch eine
gute saison
zumal ihr bei den impfungen jetzt riesen
fortschritte machen auch wenn es klar
ist dass urlaub weiter einigen krone
restriktionen unterliegen wird wir
müssen immer noch vorsichtig sein das
virus ist noch daher klinge es noch ein
weiter weg ist bis wir einigermaßen zu
früheren normalität zurückfinden wir
freuen uns über diese ermutigenden
hoffnungszeichen für die
tourismuswirtschaft und für den
deutschlandtourismus jetzt zahlt sich
aus dass wir unsere tourismusbranche
eine massive staatliche unterstützung
gegeben haben um die uns andere länder
in europa und weltweit beneiden
ja herr kollege klinge es ist besser gut
zu regieren als nicht zu regieren
wir haben wir haben das vertrauen der
branche in den letzten monaten wieder
zurückgewinnen können wir haben als cdu
csu bundesmittel fragt dann habe ich
etwas mehr zeit wir haben als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion zeit beginn der
korona pandemie auf schnelle hilfen für
die tourismusbranche getränkt und viel
erreicht durch eine jahr die spd hat
auch mitgewählt segensreich natürlich
herr kollege nützlich will es nicht
verhehlen
ihr habt da nichts falsch gemacht haben
uns mit unterstützt durch eine vielzahl
von branchen übergreifenden maßnahmen
wie dem erleichterten zugang zur
kurzarbeit kürzer war der geld zu
branchenspezifischen regelungen etwa bei
den überbrückungshilfen haben wir dazu
beigetragen dass viele in ihrer existenz
bedrohte unternehmen eine
überlebensperspektive bekommen haben
diese unternehmen können jetzt langsam
endlich wieder aus eigener kraft die
einkommen erwirtschaften was die branche
will
wir haben dabei immer wieder
nachbesserung vorgenommen uns intensiv
mit detailkritik beschäftigt und
versucht die sich eben bei vielen
einzelfragen ergebenden probleme
schnellstmöglich zu lösen
ja hier gibt es auch mal dank zu sagen
dank vor allem an der
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier und
dem tourismusbeauftragten thomas bareiß
hat sich dann für die unterstützung auch
für das offene ohr
wir waren im direkten kontakt mit der
branche gestanden und haben da einiges
an verbesserungen ich denke es
beispielsweise die provisionen bei der
überbrückungshilfe 1 ich denke man die
gewinnmargen für die reiseveranstalter
bei der überbrückungshilfe 1 wir haben
passgenaue lösung gemeinsam mit dem
wirtschaftsministerium gefunden für die
branche
dafür ein herzliches wort des dankes
thomas basler gleich wahrscheinlich
selbst noch einiges ergänzen können und
aktuelle zahlen nennen wie und in
welchem enormen umfang die
bundesregierung und allen voran das
wirtschaftsministerium die von der
korona krise massiv getroffene
tourismuswirtschaft unterstützt hat die
branche hat sich jetzt nicht mehr mit
umfassenden hygiene konzepten
vorbildlich auf die neue situation
eingestellt sondern vielfach auch die
zeit für investitionen und fortbildung
ihrer mitarbeiter genutzt
ich bin mir sicher dass wir sogar in
einigen bereichen gestärkt dass diese
krise hervorgehen können erstens gehe
ich davon aus dass deutschland weltweit
weiterhin und sogar zunehmend als
besonders sicheres reiseziel angesehen
wird und wir von einem wieder
anlaufenden internationalen reiseverkehr
profitieren können stichwort incoming
tourismus zweitens hat sich gezeigt
welche vorteile organisierte reisen in
krisenfällen bieten und da sind wir mit
unseren reisebüros in vielfältigen
reiseveranstaltern in deutschland
hervorragend aufgestellt und sogar
weltweit führend drittens auslandsreisen
sichern und schaffen viele arbeitsplätze
auch bei uns auch bei
verkehrsunternehmen und ja werden nicht
müde darauf hinzuweisen dass natürlich
auch der entwicklungspolitische aspekt
von touristischen reisen
gerade in schwellenländern in
entwicklungs und schwellenländern ganz
ganz wichtig ist in diesen ländern in
denen es keine kurzweiligkeit gibt in
denen es keine staatliche unterstützung
gibt leben viele menschen mit ihren
familien vom tourismus und ich hoffe
dass es uns wieder gelingt weltweiten
tourismus hin zu bekommen geht aber auch
nur deswegen als politiker bestätigen
wenn es uns gelingt dass carola
iris weltweit in griff zu bekommen also
da haben wir noch einen langen weg vor
uns
wir haben noch vieles zu tun sagt herr
präsident bedanke mich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen tag und danke nochmal
an die fdp das in diesem punkt
aufgesetzt hat deswegen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
sebastian münzenmaier sd ist der nächste
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren im vorliegenden antrag zu die
fdp wieder einmal das was sie eigentlich
am besten kann das aneinanderreihen von
wohlklingenden worthülsen und das
vorgaukeln einer eigenen oppositions
position und liebe liebe kollegen nur
dass man sich falsch verstehen ich
begrüße ausdrücklich wenn sie sich für
einen neustart der tourismusbranche
aussprechen und ich begrüße es
ausdrücklich dass in ihrem vorliegenden
antrag auch einige sinnvolle maßnahmen
genannt werden aber können sie denn
einmal im leben eine sache wirklich
grundsätzlich angehen
die tourismusbranche liegt am boden ist
seit monaten im lockdown weiß überhaupt
nicht mehr weiter und ihnen fällt dazu
ein das jetzt touristische
übernachtungen für geimpfte und genießen
erlaubt werden sollen ist das schon
alles
dass ein miniatur schräubchen an dem sie
hier drehen und es zeigt herr doktor
klinge sie starten gerade hier und haben
erzählen wir wollen dass die hotels für
alle wieder aufmachen dann habe ich den
antrag geguckt da stehen ist aber nicht
drin da sie entweder haben sie ihr mist
erzählt oder sie haben vergessen
nachtrag zu schreiben arbeit ist die
nicht dazu eine bude sie uns aber zu
meiner tochter ging also sie
beschäftigen sich wieder mal mit den
krümeln die die bundesregierung vom
tisch fallen lässt die fdp dabei und
kümmert sich darum
aber sie sind nicht grundsätzlich dafür
da politik zu ändern
wo ist denn ihr widerstand gegen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ideen sie groß
angekündigt haben
sie haben in den medien getönt
verfassungsbeschwerde
und wenn es drauf ankommt kneifen sie
sie haben sich einer normenkontrollklage
der opposition verweigert da wollten sie
nicht mitmachen
und jetzt kommt in ihrem antrag der
gipfel der scheinheiligkeit hören sie zu
herr doktor klinge wären sie in den
talkshows der republik als wackerer
kämpfer gegen die unsinnige
ausgangssperre inszenieren schreiben sie
im vorliegenden antrag zitiere mit
erlaubnis des präsidenten fahrten vom
oder zum flughafenbahnhof oder hafen bei
nächtlicher oder morgendlicher
gebundener abreise oder ankunftszeit
sind von der nächtlichen ausgangssperre
auszunehmen
jetzt wollen sie die nächtliche
ausgangssperre als option gar nicht mehr
kippen sondern jetzt sind sie zufrieden
mit einem halbgaren combo
bis und akzeptieren ein wahrscheinlich
rechtswidriges handeln dieser
bundesregierung meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren am bildschirm ist
zeigt sich wieder einmal es gibt keine
parteien deutschland bei der anspruch
und wirklichkeit dermaßen
auseinanderklaffen wie bei der fdp
die fdp redet groß von freiheit von
opposition von bürgerrechten oder vom
neustart der tourismuswirtschaft aber
ihr handeln beschränkt sich immer nur
auf floskeln auf ankündigungen oder wie
hier vorlegen auf minimalforderungen sie
haben das rückgrat eines gelben gummi
bärchen meine damen und herren
und sie sind alles bereit dafür zu tun
um endlich wieder an die fleischtöpfe
der regierungsbeteiligung zurückzukehren
wir als fdp fraktion wir stehen
stattdessen für einen grundsätzlichen
kurswechsel in der korona politik von
dem insbesondere die tourismuswirtschaft
ausführlich und massiv profitieren würde
wir wollen die sinnlose ausgangssperre
aufheben wir wollen gastronomie hotels
pensionen wieder öffnen und wir fordern
die bundesregierung dazu auf den
menschen ihre freiheit zurückzugeben
die tourismus branche nämlich eben kein
treiber der pandemie es gibt keine
erkenntnisse zu nennenswerten
infektionen in restaurants oder hotels
und es ist schlicht und ergreifend
unsinn dass ich mit meiner eigenen
familie zwar in der stadtwohnung aber
nicht im ferienhaus sein darf und es ist
schlicht und ergreifend unsinn das
negativ getesteten personen nur auf der
terrasse aber nicht im innenraum eines
restaurants sitzen dürfen und es
schlicht und ergreifend unsinn dass beim
ansteckungsrisiko im freien von 0,01
prozent die außengastronomie nicht für
jedermann geöffnet ist wir als fdp
fraktion wir möchten diesen unsinn
wirklich denken und ich kann sie liebe
fdp abgeordneten nur einmal mehr dazu
auffordern
entwickeln sie endlich den german mut
den sie immer so gerne mund führen und
nehmen sie ihren auftrag als
oppositionspartei endlich mal ernst ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
während das pult für den nächsten für
die nächste rednerin gerichtet wird
nutze ich die zeit für die mitteilung
dass die afg fraktion inzwischen für die
abstimmung gegen den über den
eingelegten einspruch gegen den gestern
erteilten ordnungsruf namentliche
abstimmung beantragt hat die abstimmung
findet nach der nach den ohne debatten
punkten statt
jetzt hat das wort die kollegen gabriele
hiller ohm spd sehr geehrter herr
präsident meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen über masse
klinge als tourismuspolitische
sprecherin der spd fraktion freue ich
mich dass wir heute kurz vor ende der
sitzungswoche noch einmal gelegenheit
haben hier im bundestag über tourismus
und tourismuspolitik zu debattieren
dies war und ist durch den vorliegenden
fdp antrag möglich die fdp fordert einen
bundesweit einheitlichen neustart für
die tourismus- und reisebranche
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen so frage
ich passt dieser antrag aber auch in
diese exponierte debatten zeit
ich sage nein denn der antrag kommt erst
zu spät
er ist zweitens überflüssig und er ist
drittens auch noch unglaubwürdig erstens
der antrag kommt zu spät
der tourismus nimmt ja wohlgemerkt ohne
den fdp antrag bereits wieder fahrt auf
die infektions scheint gegen bundesweit
zurück dass liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen haben wir aber mitnichten
der fdp und schon gar nicht da es die
zucker dank nein ganz im gegenteil
ginge es nach der fdp dann hätten hotels
und gaststätten und auch sämtliche
fitnessstudios in deutschland ohne
unabhängig von hohen instanzen geöffnet
nein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
waren impfungen rest die gene regeln die
beschlossene bundes notbremse und eine
starke solidarische disziplin und
schädiger menschen die die dritte corona
bälle gebrochen haben
dafür sage ich danke in fast eine
bundesländern konnten und können so und
nur deshalb beschränkungen wieder
zurückgenommen werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es zeigt
sich wieder einmal es geht der fdp
keineswegs um das wohl unserer gesamten
gesellschaft nein sie macht glasklare
klientel politik und sprint stets nur
nach der wurst die ihr die wirtschaft
vor die nase hält
zweitens der antrag ist überflüssig
es gibt ja bereits seit monaten einen
öffnungs plan für die wirtschaft seit
märz haben wir den fünf stufen plan der
öffnung schritte für alle bundesländer
vorsieht um es für sie liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der fdp die noch einmal auf
den punkt zu bringen
ab einem intelligent wird von 100 greift
die bundeseinheitliche bundes notbremse
zwischen incident 55 und 100 können die
bundesländer öffnen
auch die gastronomie kann dann draußen
wieder tische aufstellen und gäste
empfangen ab in studenzen unter 50 sind
freizeitveranstaltungen im außenbereich
möglich und weitere lockerungen im
gastgewerbe
seit april gibt es zudem die erste
modell
in regionen mit niedrigen intelligenten
können unter hygiene auflagen und mit
wissenschaftlicher begleitung öffnungen
vorgenommen werden
ich fasse zusammen sie fordern
bundesweit harmonisierte regeln haben
wir bei in- und auslands reichen testen
machen wir transparente kommunikation
geschieht bereit
schauen sie da zb einmal im tourismus
wegweiser nach
ich komme zum dritten punkt der fdp
antrag ist nicht nur überholt und
überflüssig er ist darüber hinaus
hochgradig unglaubwürdig heute fordern
sie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
fdp bundeseinheitliche standards
da stelle ich aber denn gerade noch
haben sie ein bundeseinheitliches
vorgehen abgelehnt die bundes notbremse
mit der bundeseinheitlich geregelt wird
was in der korona pandemie geschieht
wenn die inspektions tagen über 100
klettern haben sie abgelehnt und nicht
nur das sie klagen sogar dagegen ihre
argumentation vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht mit der bundes
notbremse werde nicht genügend auf die
regionalen gegebenheiten vor ort
eingegangen na prima sie schnappen nach
der wurst egal aus welcher richtung sie
kommt so ihr leben da dies aber vor
äußert sich meine letzte rede als
tourismuspolitische sprecherin ist ich
trete ja nicht wieder an halte ich mich
mit meiner kritik zurück und bedanke
mich stattdessen bei ihnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für die
jahrelange kollegiale zusammenarbeit im
tourismusausschuss mein herzlicher dank
gilt ebenso an das team im
wirtschaftsministerium anders anschluss
sekretariat und dann alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
fraktions- und abgeordnetenbüros und an
alle die ich jetzt nicht aufgezählt habe
die es aber auch verdient hätten bedankt
zu werden
ich sage danke für diese tolle zeit
danke ja ein abschieben sicherlich in
den kommenden wochen häufiger erleben
werden es werden doch zahlreiche
abgeordnete ausscheiden freiwillig oder
unfreiwillig bei gabriele hiller ohm ist
das ganz freiwillig bis ende oktober im
amt sein ja bitte bitte
die amtszeit der bundestag ändert mit
dem zusammenbruch des neu zu wählenden
bundestags und ob sie dadurch noch mal
reden es wäre ja schade wenn wir sie
ihre stimme nicht mehr vor
aber für den fall dass es so ist möchte
ich ihn für arbeit herzlich danken im
rahmen ihres mandats in dieser zeit und
in dem namen des ganzen hauses alles
gute für die weitere zukunft wünschen
und jetzt erteile ich ja wie wir das
kennen wir von schäuble spitzfindig es
sind noch zwei wochen es wird noch ein
sitzungstag im september geben
und in der tat gibt es noch die
möglichkeit vielleicht doch noch mal zu
sprechen klassenkassen jetzt für die
linke
ich bin anders als meine vorredner der
fdp sehr dankbar für diesen antrag er
ist doch für uns die möglichkeit dass
wir uns mit einer sehr gebeutelten
branche solidarisch erklären und es
lohnt sich auch über die vorschläge zu
diskutieren die die kollegen der fdp
fraktion gemacht haben viele davon
finden unsere unterstützung aber nicht
alle so zum beispiel der verlust rück
trag ich muss sie das erklären das
bedeutet dass steuern die auf gewinne
aus weit zurückliegenden jahren gezahlt
wurden wieder zurückerstattet wird an
die unternehmen könnte man ihm helfen
aber ist sehr ungerecht weil gerade neu
gegründete unternehmen oder unternehmen
die gerade investiert haben von dieser
möglichkeit nicht profitieren werden und
wir erinnern uns an die vielen solo
selbstständigen die wirklich jeden tag
um ihr überleben ringen
den es damit auch nicht geholfen aber
meine kritik richtung sollte nicht eine
andere fraktion sein sondern ganz klar
und deutlich diese regierung denn was
hat diese regierung getan um der
gebeutelten branche zu helfen
wir befinden uns in einem großen chaos
in einem flickenteppich fragen sie doch
mal ihre freunde nachbarn verwandten wo
sie hinfahren könnten pfingsten das
wissen sie nicht das bedeutet eine
enorme recherchearbeit und genau diese
koordinierung dieser unterschiedlichen
situation das hätte unsere
bundesregierung leisten müssen und doch
etwas anderes muss sie leisten
das ist die koordinierung der
überbrückungshilfe
dort gibt es im moment eine
unterschiedliche situation die einzelnen
bundesländer haben 80 bis minimal 64
prozent der überbrückungshilfen
ausgereicht und da könnte man sagen 80
ist ja schon viel aber das heißt jedes
fünfte bis jedes dritte unternehmen
wartet in diesem land auf
überbrückungshilfe stellen sie sich mal
vor wie für schlaflose nächte das für
die menschen die davon betroffen sind
bedeutet das kann nicht angehen und eine
andere forderung die mir großem schmerz
bereitet diese geht es weiter mit der
anzeigepflicht von insolvenzen meine
forderung der dreißigste vierte ist da
der letzte tag wo diese insolvenz licht
ausgesetzt ist das muss verlängert
werden
denn anders als uns gesagt wurde dass es
keine oder nicht wie nicht viele
insolvenzen gibt sagt mir das
statistische bundesamt dass
beispielsweise schon vom jahr 2009 10
auf das jahr 2020 die zahl der
eröffneten insolvenzen bei reisebüros
deutlich gestiegen ist nämlich von 34
auf 75 und bei reiseveranstaltern von 23
auf 40 also etwa verdoppelt und was wird
sich erst in diesem jahr dazu
also hier sollte man unbedingt noch mal
überlegen ob man den richtigen weg dabei
gegangen ist
ja und zum anderen ein weg aus der krise
das wissen wir alle ist impfen impfen
impfen es geht langsam vorwärts für
meine begriffe viel zu spät aber was mir
nicht macht ist dass man schon vorsorge
dafür trifft dass es den europäischen
impfpass gibt das in den arztpraxen
schnittstellen vorgehalten werden
entsprechende software aufgebaut wird
dass man mit einem druck auf den knopf
diesen im pass gespielt und jeden
menschen das dann per app beispielsweise
wieder auf sein handy spielt dann hätte
man ganz schnell den ganzen
bürokratischen wahnsinn gestoppt dazu
will ich aber nicht nur meckern
ich bin auch mal sagen ich habe mir
nämlich auch gedanken gemacht wenn ich
jetzt verantwortung tragen würde was
würde ich denn machen was kann man tun
also ich hätte viel mehr modellvorhaben
zugelassen
bei mir auf hiddensee würde es schon ein
modell verfahren geben
ich hoffe jetzt darauf dass vorpommern
rügen ein modellversuch früher schon
starten kann als das für mecklenburg
vorpommern geplant ist man munkelt jetzt
statt 14 06 16
na gut der branche hilft jeder tag ich
hätte auch mehr in forschung und
entwicklung investiert weil es gibt neue
trends und die müssen wir aufgreifen
müssen wir uns wirklich stärker stellen
beispielsweise eine andere mobilität
also dass man zukünftig nicht mehr so
viel mit dem flugzeug fliegt vor allem
innerdeutsche und innereuropäische nicht
deswegen ganz wichtig neue möglichkeiten
des reisens beispielsweise mit dem zug
nach züge vielleicht doch noch mehr
verknüpfung zwischen europäischen
metropolen verstärken das wären lösung
an
plätze und das rad ein ganz toller
mobilitäts treiber die menschen fahren
fahrrad da brauchen wir eine andere
infrastruktur um dieses zu leisten
können
aber ich wünschte mir auch dass wir an
die junge generation denken die ganz
besonders gebeutelt ist meine forderung
nach bildung und reisen zu verbinden
also bildung an einem anderen ort werde
auch jetzt die gelegenheit dass wir der
jungen generation die so viel mitgemacht
hat die möglichkeit einräumen dass
reisen mit dem lernen zu verbinden also
sagen wir uns dann neu ist ich glaube
das ist ganz wichtig dass wir hier in
eine andere zukunft gehen und ich
wünsche mir dass der tourismus
prominenter bei uns im bundestag
verankert ist auch in der
bundesregierung und ich wünsche mir dass
wir uns an die erarbeitung eines
gesetzes für den tourismus machen
hier sind es dieser branche die drei
millionen beschäftigte hat einfach
schuldig dass wir hier mehr tun
ich danke den kasten aber das mit dem
appell mehr zu tun für die
tourismusbranche
da werden sicherlich alle darin
übereinstimmen und derbe sommerurlaub
steht ja auch bevor die hoffnung doch
endlich urlaub machen zu können
markus tressel es für die coolness grün
ich glaube dass diese debatte ist jeden
fall wert ist dass wir sie heute genau
an dieser stelle führen und dafür bin
ich der fdp an dieser stelle auch
dankbar dass sie diesen antrag deswegen
hier heute vorgelegt hat weil liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen tourismus ist
ein wichtiger faktor in unseren regionen
und tourismus schafft arbeit in städten
in ländlichen räumen und erschafft
wirtschaftliche entwicklungen und was
wir nicht vergessen dürfen in vielen
regionen sichert er nicht nur
prosperität sondern auch verkehrliche
erschließung handwerksbetriebe
daseinsvorsorge die infrastruktur und
vieles mehr
und das kann man gar nicht oft genug
sagen und trotzdem ist gerade dieses
thema in der vergangenheit
ein politisches thema gewesen dass
vielfach unter dem wahrnehmungs ran da
gelaufen ist und deswegen ist es genau
richtig dass wir heute darüber zu
diskutieren wie wir die folgen für diese
wichtige branche minimieren und wie wir
gleichzeitig auch einen neuen aufbruch
wagen können für diese branche
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen so
sehr ich mich darüber freuen dass wir
heute dazu debattieren so sehr müssen
wir natürlich auch besorgt sein dass wir
nach 15 monaten pandemie an einigen
punkten immer noch wie am ersten tag
über grundlegende fragen zur erhaltung
der tourismuswirtschaft in diesem land
diskutieren müssen
die bundesregierung hat viel gemacht
kurzarbeitergeld überbrückungshilfen
aber jetzt muss es nach den
allernotwendigsten lebenserhaltenden
maßnahmen darum gehen einen plan zu
entwickeln wie der patient wieder
langfristig stabil wird liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und die
nationale tourismus strategie die dafür
extrem wichtig wäre
und ja fast das einzig größere
tourismuspolitische projekt wenn man das
so nennen möchte dieser koalition in
dieser wahlperiode war
die haben sie nicht auf die zielgerade
bekommen was sie mit corona und ihren
folgen begründen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der koalition genau das
wäre jetzt aber hilfreich mit dieser
strategie eine grundlage zu haben wie
gehen wir vor wie entwickeln wir den
tourismusstandort deutschland nach der
krise weiter
wo müssen wir stützen wo müssen wir
justieren und vor allem was können wir
aus diesen koordinations wirrwarr dieser
krise für die tourismuspolitik von bund
und ländern lernen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
entgegen dem was du gesagt hast liebe
kollegin gaby dohm wir sehen doch gerade
wieder dass die bundesländer jedes
bundesland einen anderen ansatz für
diesen neustart verfolgt und deswegen
fehlt diese abgestimmte strategie gerade
jetzt und das wird in den entscheidenden
nächsten monaten muss mutmaßlich
zumindest in ernst zunehmender tiefe so
bleiben und das ist eine fehlleistung
dieser regierungskoalition liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und eines
muss uns doch klar sein trotz der
finanziellen hilfe zählt diese krise an
den grundlagen des tourismusstandortes
deutschland viele sind in der existenz
bedroht kerstin kassner hat es gesagt
und wir müssen uns nichts vormachen ohne
konkreten plan ohne perspektive werden
wir unternehmen werden wir
leistungserbringer in den regionen
verlieren und dieser struktur verlust
ist für viele regionen schwer zu
kompensieren
und deswegen muss die avisierte hilfe
jetzt gut fließen und wir müssen auch
über einen wiederaufbau vor gerade für
kleine und mittlere unternehmen der
tourismuswirtschaft nachdenken und die
kolleginnen und kollegen haben es gesagt
dieses kompetenz-wirrwarr dass sich als
riesiges problem in den vergangenen
monaten gezeigt hat daran müssen wir
gehen der föderalismus hat sich gerade
für die tourismusindustrie für die
tourismuswirtschaft nicht von seiner
besten seite gezeigt in dieser krise
also kompetenzgerangel
abstimmungsschwierigkeiten teilweise
auch abstimmungs verweigerungen das kann
man in normalen zeiten vielleicht machen
das kann man aber nicht in einer so
tiefen krise machen und das untergräbt
auch die akzeptanz von corona maßnahmen
bei den reisenden und in der branche für
die wir auch kämpfen weil wir diese
pandemie endlich hinter uns lassen
wollen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und deshalb brauchen wir mehr tourismus
politische koordination zwischen den
bundesländern und auch auf der
europäischen ebene
es kann doch nicht sein dass wir nach 15
schmerzhaften und auch lehrreichen
monaten immer noch nicht in der lage
sind ein bundeseinheitliches vorgehen
für den neustart zu definieren mit
klaren regeln wann geht wo was mit
welchem konzept und die kolleginnen und
kollegen haben gesagt die ferien stehen
vor der tür nicht nur die pfingstferien
sondern auch bald die sommerferien und
wenn sie mit den menschen sprechen dann
ist da draußen viel konfusion niemand
blickt mehr durch wo man hinfahren kann
und welche bedingungen man erfüllen muss
um ein paar tage urlaub zu machen in
diesem land da braucht es mehr klarheit
und es braucht auch mehr gemeinsamkeit
im interesse der menschen und des
reiselandes deutschland voraussetzungen
für öffnungen war aus unserer sicht
immer dass wir die kontrolle über die
pandemie zurück erlangen dabei sind wir
jetzt endlich auf einem guten weg und
deswegen braucht es tatsächlich da jetzt
auch einen verlässlichen plan unter
welchen voraussetzungen was wie möglich
sein wird und im letzten jahr wäre die
zeit gewesen diesen plan vorzubereiten
ihn auf den weg zu bringen dass wir es
nicht getan haben auch seitens der
bundes- und landesregierungen das fällt
uns jetzt leider auf die füße und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die krise hat
die tourismus wirtschaft hart getroffen
und deswegen müssen wir die chance für
einen neustart konsequent nutzen und
vielleicht haben wir jetzt auch die
möglichkeit quasi im neustart die
branche die regionen resilient dagegen
derartige krisen zu machen
nachhaltigkeit digitalisierung
sicherheit und nicht zuletzt der schutz
von unternehmen und arbeitsplätzen im
tourismus das muss jetzt auf die agenda
national und auch europäisch die eu
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen plant ja
eine europäische agenda für tourismus
2050 das ist ein anfang aber wenn man
sich den langen zeitraum anguckt dann
ist mir das offen gestanden zu lang die
förderpolitik wird eine entscheidende
rolle spielen und wir müssen jetzt
gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass wie
angekündigt auch tatsächlich eu mittel
in die neuaufstellung unserer
tourismusdestinationen fließen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir
strukturen erhalten und vor allem nicht
eine ganze generation von jungen
touristikern gut ausgebildeten
touristikern verlieren wollen
da brauchen wir gerade jetzt kein
durcheinander sondern koordiniertes
vorgehen wir müssen der
tourismuswirtschaft helfen diese krise
zu überwinden auch weil wir damit
existenzen sichern regionen attraktiv
halten und wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
wir chancen nutzen die sich jetzt aus
dieser krise ergeben herzlichen dank
vielen dank markus kräfte der bundestag
diskutiert über die tourismuswirtschaft
ein antrag der fdp fraktion und thomas
bareiß hat jetzt das wort er ist der
tourismusbeauftragte der bundesregierung
und parlamentarischer staatssekretär
beim bundesminister für wirtschaft und
energie und zwischenzeitlich hat jetzt
hier sehen wir schon mal war es hat
jetzt hier im präsidium claudia roth
platz genommen
thomas bareiß
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren zu
beginn meiner rede ist mir immer wichtig
zu sagen dass die ihm deutscher tourist
und reisebranche in dieser zahlen die
mir eine einzigartige und auch harten
einschnitt ertrag musste damit auch
einen herausragenden beitrag geleistet
hat zur bekämpfung dieser pandemie
deshalb erst einmal den drei millionen
beschäftigte ein ganz ganz besonderes
dankeschön für ihren beitrag für diese
pandemie bekämpfung dieser einschnitt
den wir beschäftigen mussten sich
deshalb so bitter weil wir auch letzten
jahren erfolgreich war im tourismus wir
hatten jetzt jahre eine ungleiche
beliebtheit waren und fünf mal in folge
die beliebteste marke in der welt und
hatten auch damit enorm viele gäste wie
waren marktführend kulturbereich die
städtereisen geschäftsreisen kongresse
oder messen überall dort waren wir
spitze in europa und teilweise auch
weltweiten und dass das display dass wir
auch nach der panne wie übrigens
erfolgreich sind daran möchten wir
gemeinsam arbeiten des tages das weil es
uns gemeinsam im tourismusausschuss über
getragen hat das hat auch nochmal
dankeschön an alle fraktionen die dazu
beigetragen haben vielen dank auch noch
mal von oben stellvertretend für alle
die jetzt aufhören sollte aber auch
ihnen noch mal ganz ganz große mission
für die arbeit der letzten jahre auch
die see für den tourismus gemacht haben
wir haben viel getan der bundesregierung
haben die strukturerhaltung
vorangetrieben haben versucht auch dort
zu helfen wo hilfe ganz ganz dringend
notwendig war
die überbrückungshilfe 300 prozent fix
kostenerstattungen 6,4 milliarden euro
ausgezahlt 3,2 milliarden euro gingen
direkt in die tourismusbranche im
november/dezember hilfe eine wichtige
hilfspaket mit 50 prozent des umsatzes
des vorjahres eine auszahlungsquote von
94% 11,5 milliarden euro größtenteils in
tourismusbranche gegen diese geld hinein
und auch erwähnt wurden bereits die
kurzarbeitergeld insgesamt 30 milliarden
euro auch in großartigen
tourismusbranche
das zeigt wir haben enorm viel es
gemacht und haben gezeigt dass wir die
branche und die mitarbeiter nicht im
stich lassen meine damen haben jetzt
geht es darum
aus der krise wieder herauszukommen vor
allem sicher und nachhaltig die
unternehmen zu begleiten und ich glaube
dass das wichtige thema ist dass wir
impfen und testen und damit sicherheit
auch für jeden reisenden schaffen und
ich bin froh und dankbar dass wir
bereits 37 prozent der menschen in
deutschland mit der erstimpfung
versorgung konnte neun millionen
menschen haben schon die zweite impfung
erhalten wir haben bundesweit eine
zuverlässige test strategie auch das
zeigt dass wir vor ort sicherheit
schaffen können und ich glaube das
wichtigste ist überhaupt dass wir auch
in dieser partie nie erlebt haben dass
die menschen vor ort verantwortung
übernehmen können oder ford genau wissen
was sie tun deshalb auch da haben wir
großes vertrauen das wort auch ihr
enormes geleistet wird
ich freue mich dass wir in dieser woche
und auch nächste woche im übrigen teil
der bundesländer wieder öffnen können
cafés biergärten restaurants und bars
kneipen gaststätten werden wieder öffnet
es sind ganz ganz wichtiges signal auch
für die branche und wird wieder weiter
wir brauchen keine pläne waren keine
großen modelle wir müssen jetzt öffnen
und ist das wichtigste signal auch für
alle in dieser branche urlaub in hotels
in pensionen ferienwohnungen sind in
vielen bundesländern mit auflagen aber
wieder auch in pfingsten und nach
pfingsten machbar
auch das glaube ich ganz ganz wichtiges
signal dass sehr große hoffnung auch
wieder gibt wir ermöglichen reisen auch
nicht nur in deutschland sondern
europaweit haben dazu auch vieles
letzten woche beigetragen
bundeseinheitliche regelungen für die
impfte und genesene fläche die test fest
strategie eine neue und auch
unbürokratische einreißen ordnung ohne
quarantäne sondern eine ganz klare
strategie wie testen im vordergrund und
auch als ein risikogebiet kann man dann
ohne quarantäne nach deutschland
einreisen und die sichere grundlage für
die zukunft wird der digitale corona
impfpass geben die ab juni dann auch
bereit steht und dann auch sicheres
reisen ganz europa für alle wieder
möglich macht meine damen und herren
in den letzten monaten haben wir klar
ist sehr schmerzhaft erfahren wie
wichtig es ist für uns menschen zu
begegnen fest zu besuchen restaurants zu
besuchen urlaub zu machen zu reisen
neues zu erleben heraus zu kommen und
ich bin davon überzeugt der wunsch nach
reisen und nach wieder neues zu erleben
ist so groß wie noch nie deshalb bin ich
davon überzeugt dass wir vor einem
großartigen den sommer stehen vor einem
großartigen zweiten halbjahr stehen in
diesem jahr
und dass die deutsche tourismusbranche
deutschen bei den beschäftigten wieder
viele viele neue gäste gemeinsam in
diese stadt saison starten können
vielen dank vielen dank thomas bach
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen nächster redner für die
fdp fraktion christoph neumann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin ehrwürdige
mitglieder dieses wohnhauses geneigte
zuschauer an den heimischen
fernsehgeräten
der vorliegende antrag der fdp er ist
ein versuch vertrauen für den tourismus
zurückzugewinnen ist aller ehren wert
aber warum haben wir dieses vertrauen
überhaupt erst verloren
warum antworten immer mehr deutsche mit
unverständnis auf die maßnahmen dieser
regierung
ganz einfach die regierung hat die
unterstützung des deutschen volkes
verloren
[Applaus]
zu ostern durften die ersten urlauber
unser land verlassen ich betone durften
der abgeordnete und genosse professor dr
lauterbach von der spd versuchte sogar
den bürgern dies zu verleiten und sagte
der spanischen regierung eine gewisse
schummelei nach wie aus den medien zu
erfahren war
dabei zeigten die verantwortlichen auf
den balearen wie tourismus auch in
zeiten von corona möglich ist
die hygienemaßnahmen wurden entsprechend
der bedürfnisse angepasst
es waren sogar schulen geöffnet und die
gäste aus deutschland wurden mit großer
freude empfangen
zu dieser gleichen zeit verkauft sich
unsere regierung aus reiner furcht in
ihre berliner amtsstuben
die deutsche tourismuswirtschaft mit
drei millionen beschäftigten hat seit
langem sinnvolle konzepte für die
eröffnung des tourismus erarbeitet wenig
davon ist die politik eingeflossen
hören wir an dieser stelle doch endlich
einmal auf die vertreter der praxis sie
arbeiten jeden tag für das wohl ihrer
gäste und wissen was nötig ist um diese
zu schützen
die bürger in unserem land wollen ihre
freiheit zurück die freiheit ihren
aufenthaltsort selbst zu bestimmen ohne
bevormundung aus berlin
der geschätzte kollegen möchten sie
nicht auch den bürgern unseres landes
ihre freiheit wieder geben
liebe kollegen der fdp das grundübel
haben sie ja bereits richtig erkannt das
infektionsschutzgesetz dieser regierung
zerstört vertrauen nur ihr wunsch nach
einem bundesweiten öffnungs konzept wird
ein wunsch bleiben und das wissen sie
bund und länder haben auch in der not
nicht zueinandergefunden der öffnungs
wettbewerb ist schon längst im gange die
wir tagtäglich in allen medien sehen
können
pfingsten steht vor der tür unsere
familien wollen in den sommerurlaub sie
planen schon helfen wir ihn endlich
dabei geben sie den menschen in
deutschland ihre freiheit zurück es lebe
unser schönes urlaubsland deutschland
ich danke ihnen für das aktive zuhören
dankeschön kostenfrei der nächste redner
in der debatte über die
tourismuswirtschaft ein antrag der fdp
den die abgeordneten hier beraten kommt
von der spd bernd rützel und er ist der
mitglied im ausschuss für tourismus
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen aber
ganz besonders liebe gabriele hiller ohm
auch wenn wir nicht wissen ob das heute
deine letzte rede zum tourismus war es
geht ja noch ein paar monate
so will ich aber auch die möglichkeit
nutzen die ihr für 19 jahre hier im
deutschen bundestag im bereich tourismus
zu danken du hast hier viel gearbeitet
viel bewegt hat der einen guten namen
und gute verbindungen das ist der
unterschied
das ist der unterschied zu plakativen
anträgen oder zu reden die wir gerade
eben gehört haben vielen dank liebe
tabelle für deine arbeit
ich bin aber schon auch froh dass die
fdp zu dieser stunde und auch in dieser
in diesem umfang es ermöglicht dass wir
über den neustart reden jedem lechzt
doch danach dass wir wieder raus können
dass wir wieder das genießen wollen was
uns so lieb war und wenn wir gesehen
dass die korona zahlen deutlich sinken
dass die situation auf den
intensivstationen sich leicht aber
stetig entspannt wenn wir sehen dass die
impfungen an fahrt aufnehmen und wir uns
alle auf einen schönen sommer und
nächste woche machen die freibäder auf
freuen
dann ist es aber trotzdem wichtig jetzt
maß und verstand zu wahren ermöglichen
was möglich ist und dabei trotzdem
vorsichtig und umsichtig zu bleiben das
muss jetzt gelten und wir haben ja hier
einen bundeseinheitlichen rahmen auch
geschaffen mit dieser buntes notbremse
aber ich sage auch
es ist ein großer flickenteppich nach
wie vor die länder können sie oftmals
nicht einigen und warten auch mit
koordinierung zu lang das ist
verantwortungslos das ist bizarr und das
hilft auch der reisebranche nicht und es
ist für viele reisende auch nicht
nachvollziehbar ich will ein beispiel
nennen aus meinem wahlkreis in
unterfranken wir liegen ganz nah an der
hessischen landesgrenze und am
pfingstmontag also nächste woche geld
sind wieder in bayern verschiedene
angebote die zugelassen werden
reisebusse zum beispiel dürfen dann
wieder fallen und seit gestern ist ein
papier der bayerische staatsregierung im
umlauf das nennt sich rahmenkonzept und
regelt die bedingungen unter denen
touristische dienstleistungen vom
kommenden montag eben wieder angeboten
werden dürfen ich will diesmal
freundlich zusammenfassen dieses papier
es ist kompliziert es ist kompliziert
weil natürlich die regelungen
unterschiedlich sind weil der bayerische
ministerpräsident die zügel gerne kurz
hält und deswegen hatten gerade aus
meinem wahlkreis busunternehmer die idee
farbe schnell über die grenze nach
hessen und fangen um ganz bayern
außenrum nach italien zum beispiel und
das ist ja schwierig und das versteht
auch niemand und dass die leute denken
ja ein bisschen verrückt deswegen
brauchen wir planungssicherheit was wir
aber anbieten können und bereits
geregelt haben ist eine orientierung an
infektionszahlen was wir nicht anbieten
können
das muss man auch deutlich sagen sind
aussagen über die weitere entwicklung
der infektionszahlen es gibt prognosen
die als orientierung helfen aber ob sie
verlässlich sind und wie das im juni im
juli im august im september ist weiß
hier niemand und ja ist so bilden sich
das vielleicht ein aber es weiß niemand
wie es ist und deswegen müssen
versprechen seriös sein
es wurde hier auch schon angesprochen
dass ich es weisen aber auch verändern
risen verändert sich die leute wollen
mehr sicherheit sicherheit dass
krankenhäuser in der nähe sind
sicherheit dass man auch wieder
zurückkommt sicherheit dass man umbuchen
kann dass man flexibel sein kann
das thema nachtzüge wofür ich als
eisenbahner besonders dankbar bin ist
ein wichtiges thema die kollegin kassen
hat es ja angesprochen radwege
nachhaltigkeit ist wichtig und ich will
mit einem zitat welches alexander von
humboldt zugeschrieben wird enden der
soll gesagt haben die gefährlichste
weltanschauung ist die weltanschauung
der die die welt nie angeschaut haben
deswegen ist reisen wichtig bildet und
es ist auch nicht schlecht sagt
eisenmann wenn man manchmal auch ist
flugzeug benutzt wildern vielen dank
bernd rützel danke ihnen
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
roman müller
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin geschätzt
kolleginnen und kollegen in der tat die
tourismuswirtschaft ist wahrscheinlich
die branche in unserem land die als
erstes von der kommune pandemie
betroffen war und wahrscheinlich auch
noch am längsten von der krise und
erfolgen betroffen sein wird dann nehme
ich das paar trat herr rützel richtig
gesagt wir können alle nicht wissen was
eventuell ein des tages noch passieren
mag aber genau deswegen ist es halt eben
auch so wichtig dass wir dieser branche
jetzt entschlossen helfen
mein eindruck und das ist nicht nur
meiner dass es auch der viele aus der
branche ist dass die bundesregierung
relativ schnell und auch großzügig damit
umgeht wenn es darum geht
freiheitsrechte einzuschränken
möglichkeiten dieser branche zu erhalten
dass sie sich selbst ernähren kann und
nicht auf staatliche zuschüsse
angewiesen ist und wenn es aber darum
geht dass man dieser branche konkret
hilft dann dauert es ewigkeiten ja die
branche beispielsweise wartet nach wie
vor das hat marcel klinge lag schon
ausgeführt auf eine passende regelung
für die verbundunternehmen und das auch
mal klappte beziffern
das sind vielleicht nur 150 unternehmen
dahinter stecken aber mindestens bis zu
200.000 mitarbeiter und da frage ich
mich schon ganz ehrlich über
bundesregierung und liebe große
koalition
warum machen sie denn da nichts warum
passiert denn nicht endlich etwas und
warum lassen die leute da im regen
stehen und das führt mich der aktion
dass das muss ich so deutlich sagen dass
das auseinanderfallen von eigener
wahrnehmung und wirklichkeit anscheinend
gerade bei der großen koalition am
meisten ihrem auto vorhanden ist ich
möchte ihnen das auch ganz deutlich
machen wir haben seit monaten im
tourismusausschuss eine anhörung nach
der anderen ist kommen immer wieder
dieselben themen auf und wenn ich dann
frauen ihnen vorgaben höre das jetzt
also sie ist wunderlich verwunderlich
finden dass wir eine bundeseinheitliche
strategie fordern oder dass wir gegen
maßnahmen wie gegen die ausgangs
beschränkungen klage erheben dann frage
ich mich haben sie da eigentlich mal
zugehört also die leute es sage die
ganze zeit dass das schädlich ist für
den tourismus wir tun etwas dagegen oder
möchte damit erreichen dass das ab
geholfen wird und dann wundern sie sich
dass wir das machen dafür habe ich
keinerlei verständnis und dann zu guter
letzt möchte auch noch mal weil kerstin
kassner hatte das gerade eben auch schon
angesprochen auf das thema der insolvenz
insolvenzantragspflicht eingehen wir
haben hier ebenfalls eine situation die
ausgesprochen schwierig ist gerade im
tourismus ist es eben so dass einige
betriebe immer noch nicht keine
hilfsmaßnahmen erhalten haben
und was passiert nun seit dem 30 nach
dem 30 04 müssen nun wieder insolvenzen
beantragt werden das ist
ordnungspolitisch richtig aber es ist
ordnungspolitisch falsch dass gesunde
unternehmen dafür nur im grunde
insolvenz anmelden müssen weil
staatlicher hand weil die staatliche
staatliches handeln fehlt und die
bundesregierung da nicht entspreche
hilfe leistet herzlich
vielen dank belegen die nächste rednerin
hier in der debatte kommt von der
cdu/csu-fraktion astrid damerow
sie ist stellvertretende vorsitzende im
ausschuss für tourismus
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen ja auch
ich habe mir in den vergangenen monaten
so manches mal mehr einheitlichere
bundeseinheitliche regeln gewünscht
dieser wunsch war immer dann besonders
ausgeprägt wenn die ministerpräsidenten
runden mit der kanzlerin endeten
denn es gab häufig einen durchaus
ausgeprägten gemeinsamen willen aber in
der umsetzung von einheitlichen
maßnahmen haperte es dann hinterher das
gab heute dann besonders virulent
es wurde dann besonders virulent als wir
im frühjahr steigende infektionszahlen
hatten und vor diesem hintergrund war es
richtig dass wir eine bundeseinheitliche
notbremse geschlossen haben um die
richtigerweise da wir ja ein föderaler
staat sind das wird so ein bisschen
vergessen in der diskussion heute heftig
gerungen haben und zum thema für der
allerstadt will ich auch sagen gerade
wir touristiker betonen doch bei jeder
gelegenheit wie wichtig es ist dass
tourismus neutral betrachtet wird weil
eben die gegebenheiten in unseren
bundesländern sehr unterschiedlich sind
und deshalb bin ich nach wie vor der
ansicht die kollegin hat es sehr
deutlich gemacht die notbremse ist
richtig aber dass darunter müssen die
bundesländer in ihrer eigenen hoheit
entscheiden und ich verstehe ehrlich
gesagt ihre aufregung in der fdp und
durchaus auch bei den grünen nicht so
ganz denn an der einen oder anderen der
landesregierung sind sie durchaus
beteiligt als schleswig holsteiner bin
sage ich ganz offen bin ich sehr froh
dass wir diese differenzierte
betrachtung haben denn ohne diese
differenzierung deren in meinem
bundesland die modellregionen so nicht
möglich gewesen
gerade in meinem wahlkreis mit einer
intelligenz von in den letzten wochen
dauerhaft um die
30 haben wir die modellregion der ganze
kreis nordfriesland und die gemeinde
büsum sind modellregionen von erster mai
bis montag gewesen
das klingt toll und es klingt auch so
einfach war es nicht auch um die
bedingungen eben dieser modellregion ist
heftig gerungen worden ist diskutiert
worden sie erfordert von allen akteuren
die sich daran beteiligen ein hohes maß
an einsatz und an disziplin
im übrigen haben sich auch nicht alle
touristischen unternehmen daran
beteiligt auch das gehört zur wahrheit
dazu das ist ihr gutes recht und ich
finde das muss man auch akzeptieren und
auch wirklich hinnehmen so daneben lief
aber auch die diskussion und das sage
ich jetzt durchaus als touristikerin
aber eben auch als abgeordnete meines
wahlkreises das eben auch die bürger
gibt einwohner in so einem kreis auch
durchaus ängste entwickelt haben das
kann ich nicht einfach wegwischen und
das haben im übrigen auch die
touristiker vor ort nicht einfach
weggewischt gehen möchte ich an dieser
stelle in dem joggen explizit hier
einmal danken wie verantwortungsvoll und
wie auf kritikfähig sie mit dieser
situation umgegangen sind und mit wie
viel einsatz sie die bedingungen und die
voraussetzung für diesen modellen region
geschaffen haben
es ist eine chance gewesen wir haben sie
nutzen können weil sie eine niedrige
inzidenz haben aber auch nur deshalb und
deshalb nochmal ich wünschte mir keine
bundeseinheitlichen regeln zu einer
öffnung denn dann wäre das nicht möglich
gewesen
ich finde das sollte man an der stelle
dann schon auch immer einmal betrachten
modellregion ist gut sie hat bei uns
jetzt so einer landesweiten öffnung
geführt andere bundesländer wehren
nachziehen aber wie gesagt wir werden um
einen flickenteppich in den nächsten
wochen nicht herumkommen das ist der
vielfalt übrigens finde ich als
touristikerin der ausgesprochen schönen
vielfalt unseres landes geschuldet und
ich finde diese geduld sollten wir auf
haben und wenn ich mich mit den bürgern
in meinem wahlkreis unterhalte dann sind
sie durchaus in der lage sich darüber
gedanken zu machen wohin sie in urlaub
fahren und welche regeln sie dort
erfüllen müssen
das haben wir früher nämlich auch getan
also ja nicht so dass immer alles
überall gleich ist insofern würde ich
mal sagen lieber masse klinge der wunsch
nach bundeseinheitlichen regeln hätte
durchaus auch an der nahe geschenk sein
können und deshalb ist es gut und
richtig wie die bundesregierung das
gemeinsam mit den bundesländern geregelt
hat und jetzt verehrte qualitäten mehr
zulegen gilt in der tat nach vorne zu
schauen
wir haben natürlich noch nicht für alle
lösungen so wie wir sie uns wünschen
die verbundenen unternehmen sind
angesprochen worden es ist schwierig sie
haben es gesagt für unsere
busunternehmen bei länderübergreifenden
reisen das stimmt auch ebenso werden wir
uns mit dem thema auseinandersetzen dazu
sind wir bereits im gespräch mit dem
staatssekretär
wie gehen wir um mit arbeitskräfte
gewinnung in den nächsten wochen und
monaten für unsere tourismuswirtschaft
all das sind herausforderungen die sind
uns sehr wohl bewusst dafür liebe fdp
hat ihren antrag nicht gebraucht das
wissen wir daran arbeiten wir in
vielerlei hinsicht gemeinsam mit unserem
koalitionspartner und deshalb werden wir
ihren antrag ablehnen und aber
selbstverständlich mit ihnen gemeinsam
im tourismusausschuss rede dass auch in
der vergangenheit gewöhnt waren bei der
kollegiale zusammenarbeit
arbeiten zum wohle unseres tourismus und
der menschen in unserem land ganz
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
astrid damerow hier mit einer gegenrede
zum antrag der fdp zu
tourismuswirtschaft der nächste redner
in dieser debatte kommt von den
sozialdemokraten frank junge er ist
vorsitzender im unterausschuss regionale
wirtschaftspolitik und erp
wirtschaftspläne und da sehen wir noch
schon und er hat jetzt hier als nächster
in der debatte um den antrag der fdp
hebt zum wirtschafts tourismus
wirtschaft das wort frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie mich zunächst vorausschicken
dass die unternehmen die gerade im
mittelstand den tourismus in unserer
republik aufrecht halten und sondern
aller respekt verdient haben und wir als
bundesregierung und als bundestags
koalition eine ganze menge auf den weg
gebracht haben um denen zu helfen
das scheint so ein bisschen aus der
debatte zu geraten wir haben die
umsatzeinbrüche ausgeglichen wir haben
fixe kostenerstattung vorgenommen wir
haben mehrwertsteuer absenkungen
vorgenommen das alles hilft der branche
in einer zeit wo sie es dringend braucht
und dann über marcel klinge ich wünschte
mir ein stück weit mehr
sozialdemokratische gedanken weise bei
euch in der fraktion denn dann würdet
ihr natürlich nicht nur zu recht die
unternehmen oben einstellen
ihr wurde die dort auf die gleiche ebene
heben können wie die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer
denn ohne diese arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer wäre dieses zusammenspiel
überhaupt nicht möglich und da ist es
insbesondere unserer fraktion und olaf
scholz zu verdanken
dass wir mit dem kurzarbeitergeld mit
den investitionen in qualifikationen
ausbildung eine ganze menge auch für die
tourismus-branche geleistet haben
dann will ich noch mal hervorheben wenn
wir über die bundes notbremse reden dann
reden wir über ein instrument das wirkt
seit der einführung sind die inzidenz
werte um fast 100% punkte gefallen
das zeigt dass das den menschen zugute
kommt der wirtschaft der gastronomie und
dem tourismus und hier sage ich noch mal
herr müller böhm dass sie sich dieser
maßnahme komplett enthalten haben sie
haben dagegen gestimmt und damit einen
katalog ja abgelehnt der am ende ja dazu
führt dass wir bessere voraussetzungen
der gesellschaft haben die die
wirtschaft braucht um am ende
voranzukommen und entsprechend auch
lockerungen zu erfahren herr kollege
erlernen sie eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen von herrn hoffmann fdp muss
man fdp kaufmann bitte gerne ja vielen
dank herr kollege dass er die
zwischenfrage zu lassen
ihre redner von der spd haben ja an die
vernunft appelliert auch an die
sicherheit appelliert aber ich empfinde
da eine gewisse wahrnehmungsstörung sie
können das nicht empfinden weil sie
vielleicht ein bisschen weiter weg von
der schweizer grenze wohnen wenn sie ein
touristisches reisebüro haben in
südbaden dann kommen ihnen tränen die
augen weil in der schweiz konnten sie
immer verreisen zum beispiel in
risikogebiete wie ägypten
die zeit des konnten die reisen konnten
jederzeit verkauft werden gar kein
problem auch in deutschland nicht
möglich
und sie haben auch in der schweiz alle
skilifte auf graf die hotels waren immer
auf und als wir die bundes notbremse die
gerade sie gelobt haben in kraft
getreten ist hat die schweiz alles
aufgemacht und wenn sie jetzt die
inzidenz verläufe von brighton staaten
vergleichen sehen sie das genau dasselbe
ist finde den finden sie hier einen
fehler
herr kollege
hoffmann ich will ihn dort entgegnen
dass die maßnahmen die wir zur
bekämpfung der korona pandemie auf die
beine gestellt haben aus meiner sicht
genau die richtigen sind
ich halte es auch für klug dass wir uns
stets an den gleichen parameter und zur
beurteilung der lage festgehalten haben
und wenn wir unter diesem gesichtspunkt
feststellen müssen dass mit beschluss
der bundesländer am 25.04 der instanz
wird bei uns eine republik bei 166
gelegen hat da muss man realisieren dass
wir bis heute die inzidenz senken
konnten auf 68 also selbst wenn man
selbst wenn man unter dem gesichtspunkt
so argumentierten sie ist doch deutlich
dass sich die absenkung des incidents
wertes auf irgendetwas zurückführen
lassen muss und das ist aus meiner sicht
die bundes notbremse ich fahre in meiner
rede fort ich will zur
widersprüchlichkeit ihres antrags über
marcel klinge auch nochmal anführen dass
wir und sie halten ja auch die
freiheitlichen rechte der bürgerinnen
und bürger immer so weit hoch dass wir
ja am 6 am 65
die möglichkeit gehabt haben hier im
deutschen bundestag alle darüber zu
entscheiden
das geimpft und genesene von den
einschränkungen im rahmen der korona
maßnahmen ausgenommen werden können
wir haben das beschlossen weil wir damit
nicht nur sehen dass wir denen ihre
eingeschränkten rechte zurück geben wir
haben an dieser stelle natürlich auch
die wirtschaft im blick weil sich damit
auch perspektiven im rahmen von
marktteilnehmern und bieten also hier
frage ich mich warum sie wenn ihnen das
so wichtig ist die dort ihre stimme
verwehrt haben
ich will ich will zu anderen
widersprüchlichkeiten in ihrem antrag
gar nichts sagen weil wir da ein stück
weit die zeit davonläuft ich möchte aber
noch mal auf ein zusammenhang hinweisen
der hier nach meinem dafürhalten viel zu
kurz gekommen ist
wir alle sind uns darüber im klaren
hoffentlich dass wir erst dann über
verlässliche und vor allen dingen
dauerhafte rückkehr zur normalität nur
dann reden können wenn wir dauerhaft die
inzidenz werte in allen bereichen
unserer gesellschaft zurückfahren können
das ist doch es ist doch liegt doch als
als
als erkenntnis klar auf dem tisch und
vor diesen hin vor diesem hintergrund
kann es aus meiner sicht nur darum gehen
dass wir mit aller macht und mit aller
kraft die wir haben die impfkampagne die
es in den ländern angelaufen ist und gut
läuft weiter aufrecht erhalten und vor
dem hintergrund kann ich nur noch einmal
jens spahn darum bitten dass ja alles
mögliche dafür tut genügend impfstoff
bereit zu stellen damit wir genau an
diesem punkt die fortschritte erreichen
die wir mit einer durchimpfungsrate
brauchen um am ende dann wirklich zu
verlässlichen und dauerhaften
lockerungen zu kommen oder einen letzten
hinweis möchte ich geben es wurde hier
schon angesprochen ich glaube gerade für
die tourismusbranche ist ein
fälschungssicherer digitaler impfausweis
von höchster not und hier fordere ich
auch jens spahn auf schon bevor wir in
europa einen europaweiten eine
europaweite möglichkeit der digitalen
erfassung des impfstatus haben in
deutschland eine fälschungssichere
möglichkeit einzuführen das hilft der
tourismusbranche
das hilft im einzelhandel und vor allen
dingen ist es so dass es die
ordnungsämter in den kommunen entlastet
weil die sonst mit der überprüfung
alleingelassen werden
vielen dank vielen dank der letzte
redner hier in der debatte um die
tourismuswirtschaft den antrag der fdp
kommt jetzt von der cdu csu michael bont
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja wir sehen
uns alle
nach dem neustart des tourismus und
mittlerweile lassen die abklingende
pandemie und auch der im fortschritt die
hoffnung langsam auch wieder zur
realität werden und dort wo der
tourismus bereits wieder angelaufen ist
zb in den modellregionen im norden da
brummt der tourismus auch schon wieder
und zwar ganz gewaltig und wie der
fdp-antrag bestätigt
es wird auch schon wieder kräftig
gebucht vor allem innerhalb deutschlands
denn viele menschen haben deutschland
als urlaubsland neu entdeckt und den
urlaub im eigenen land wieder neu
schätzen gelernt
schließlich stellt sich hier eben nicht
die frage was mache ich denn wenn ich
krank werde lasse ich mich aus fliegen
wo gibt es denn in der nähe ein gutes
krankenhaus und die menschen sind
urlaubs hungrig und es geht uns doch
ehrlicherweise allen so der neustart
wird also unter thomas bareiß hat schon
angesprochen ganz automatisch kommen
wenn die länder der reihe nach in den
kommenden tagen und wochen ihre
urlaubsdestinationen wieder öffnen
der fdp-antrag liefert eine drei seiten
lange zustandsbeschreibung der ich
größtenteils nicht widersprechen will
lieber masse klinge die liste von
möglichen maßnahmen danach dieser
beschreibung umfasst am ende nur sechs
punkte von denen die allermeisten
ländersache sind
da ist zum beispiel die förderung nach
einem eröffnungs konzept inklusive
regeln fest und im nachweis hygiene
konzept etc oder die aufhebung von
touristischen übernachtungs verboten
das sind gute punkte die aber in unserer
bundesrepublik nicht von uns hier
geregelt werden sondern von den ländern
und es fordern sie wiederholt und wir
erklären wiederholt gerne
die rechtslage damit das geklärt ist und
auch bei den grünen hatte damen und
herren an dieser stelle wollen wir uns
ganz kurz aus dem geschehen hier im
plenarsaal ausklinken wir kommen dann
gleich zurück aber im moment wollen wir
ihnen ganz kurzen auftritt von heiko
maas dem deutschen außenminister in
israel zeigen er ist heute morgen ein
aufgebrochen wird gespräche früher mit
der israelischen seite auch mit der
palästinensischen seite und er hat heute
morgen bereits mit seinem amtskollegen
gabi aschkenasi gesprochen und sich
danach vor den kameras geäußert und das
wollen wir ihnen nicht vorenthalten